[Music]
do you plan to make a new year's
resolution will you make more than one
38% of Americans will make a resolution
according to a new poll from its os-- of
that group slightly more plan to make
multiple resolutions instead of just one
in the Ipsos poll of those who plan to
make resolutions money matters such as
saving more buying a house or paying off
debt shared top billing with eating
healthier and being more active rankings
slightly lower was losing weight though
getting in shape is consistently popular
in the polls helping Americans to keep
those promises many will wear a Fitbit
or a SmartWatch 19% in a new Gallup
polls say they currently own one and 15%
have worn one in the past how many
people will keep their New Year's
resolutions 80% in to 2018 you go poll
agree that most people don't stick to
those resolutions whether you make a
resolution or not
AEI wishes you the best in the new year
and good luck keeping those resolutions
have you made a new year's resolution
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI